We've been using the function,
Math.random, in our dice rolling program.
And we know that random is a Math function that Java provides,
that outputs a random double between 0 and 1.
But how did you know that this function would produce the 0-1 output?
We walked through how to use it together.
And what about our println function that we've used a lot?
How would you have known how to print a line of text if we didn't go over it first?
You wouldn't have, and that's where documents come in useful.
You can find out more about any built-in Java functions like Math functions or
println functions just by looking at the available Java Documentation.
Documentation is a fundamental feature of any big programming language.
It's a huge resource for programmers,
because good documentation provides all the information we need to know.
It tells us about built- in functions as well as different variable types,
and shows us how to use these functions in our own programs.
So programmers of all levels use documentation regularly.
Java is owned by Oracle,
who maintains the most up to date Java documentation on their website.
And I'll provide the link to the latest documentation page for Java in the notes below.
Next, let's dive into some documentation and learn more about Math functions.
To learn more about Math functions,
the first thing we need to do is search for the information we want.
Since we're interested in Math,
let's search something like Math java 8 documentation.
So we've specified what we're looking to learn more about Math,
our version of Java,
Java 8, and that we're looking for documentation.
And any similar searches should work just as well.
And our first page result looks promising.
It's a docs.oracle.com page.
So let's click on this.
This takes us to the Math java documentation page.
So let's look at what this has in it.
This will be the general structure for all of Oracle's documentation pages.
First, we can see that it says Class Math.
And the class is something that groups
together multiple functions and sometimes variables,
and it's why when we've used Math functions like random,
we've had to say Math.random in our function call and not just random by itself.
This way, Java knows that this function can be found in the Math class.
And we'll get into classes more later on when we talk about objects,
so don't worry too much about this for now.
Next, there's this general description of Math,
and it tells us that the class Math contains methods,
and methods are the same thing as functions.
So it says it contains methods or functions for
performing basic numeric operations like exponents,
logs, square roots, and trig functions.
Cool. Then if we scroll down more,
there's more description, and the next thing we see is a Field Summary.
And a field is just a name for a variable that's part of a class,
like how functions are part of the Math class.
For functions in the Math class,
we've had to say something like Math.random or
Math.whatever function name in order to call them,
and these variables are accessed in the same way.
So we can use the exact value of something like pi,
which is around 3.14,
by saying Math.pi in our programs.
But don't worry too much about fields for now because we're
mainly interested in the functions that Java provides.
The next section is called Method Summary,
and this is the section that we're most interested in.
This summary has a list of all the functions that Java provides.
These are functions that we can use like Math.random and there are a lot.
They're all listed in alphabetical order.
Let's scroll down to the one we're interested in, random.
Here's our familiar random function.
It's listed in the method summary,
and it contains a short description.
This says, it returns a double value greater than or equal to zero and less than one.
And we can click on random for even more information.
So, let's do that. Here's the documentation for the random function.
We see the start of its function definition,
public static double random with empty parentheses.
Double is its return type,
and it means is returning a double as output.
Then this page has a brief description of the entire function,
and it tells you exactly what it does.
It tells you it returns a double value
between 0 and 1 and it tells you a bit about how that value is chosen.
It also has this return section that tells you
exactly what return value you should expect.
A pseudorandom double greater than or equal to 0.0 And less than 1.0.
So just by looking at this documentation,
we can tell exactly what this function does,
what it returns, and if it requires any input data.
Next, we'll look at the documentation for a Math function that we
haven't seen and see if we can figure out what it does.